[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
porque hacemos todo lo que es
socialmente correcto porque
especialmente las mujeres nos dejamos
llevar por este mandato porque debemos
ser perfectas porque no nos inculcan el
practicar la valentía
porque tenemos que seguir estos caminos
ya predeterminados
por supuesto yo seguí este mandato al
pie del cañón y así fue que transite en
mi vida profesional llegando a la
cúspide de mi carrera de la cual podía
pretender llegué a ser gerente general
de una compañía multinacional me creía
invencibles al estilo mujer maravilla
dos tercios de nuestra vida suceden
trabajando es casi el 70% alguna vez
pararon para reflexionar si realmente lo
que estaban haciendo los hacía sentir
felices si están haciendo los sueños y
están cumpliendo esos sueños que ustedes
tenían si realmente lo que estás
haciendo los está haciendo felices
está totalmente definido que una vez que
nosotros terminamos la escuela
secundaria debemos elegir una carrera
universitaria
y por supuesto transitar estos años de
la universidad
se pusieran a pensar que esta decisión
la tenemos que tomar cuando tenemos
entre 17 y 18 años el topic etapa
traumática dura donde estamos
aprendiendo a pasar de la niñez a la
madurez a la adultez esta adolescencia
entonces no sonaría alocado pensar que a
la mitad de su vida y por qué no antes
le hagan jaque mate a esa carrera que
eligieron
porque realmente la tuvieron que decidir
cuando estaban pasando por una etapa
donde no sabían lo que querían
patear el tablero barajar y dar de nuevo
ser los artífices de nuestro propio
destino
ya tengo más de 40 años y la verdad que
elijo mi campo de acción y elijo ampliar
mi campo de acción no ir por este camino
que fue predeterminado
ya no me quiere dejó llevar por el
mandato ya no me dejo llevar por lo
socialmente correcto que las mujeres
debemos hacer sino que después de este
año de hacer lo que está totalmente
impuesto decido romper mi zona de
confort patear el tablero hacer lo que
me gusta hacer lo que me apasiona
ustedes saben lo que les apasiona porque
a mí me apasionan los autos
donde yo nací era la casa donde abajo
estaba el taller mecánico familiar
a mí me encantaba llevar la bicicleta y
jugar con papá me ponía al lado de él
con la bicicleta jugaba con las
herramientas y trataba de imitar lo que
él hacía era sumamente feliz
se imaginan que para la familia no que
una mujer continúe este legado familiar
no era lo que estaba planeado y ahí ya
me abrieron la puerta para un caminito
que estaba predeterminado y les diría
casi enrejado
y así fue que estudió licenciatura en
comercialización mientras estaba
trabajando ya había comenzado a trabajar
porque nos dicen bueno hay que tener
experiencia laboral mientras nosotros
estamos estudiando también tenemos que
seguir capacitándonos así que hizo un
máster en negocios internacionales
trabajé en la argentina trabajé en el
exterior y así fue que a través de este
famoso techo de cristal que podemos
decir del mundo corporativo y ser la
gerente general de una compañía
multinacional muy importante
la tapa del diario diría pero que
profesional exitosa casadas de 23 años
con juan manuel mamá de vicente y de
paloma
el tener una hija mujer me hizo
reflexionar sobre su futuro
yo había hecho este caminito totalmente
perfecto y les diría que había hecho el
estilo el cuento de hansel y gretel
había dejado las miguitas para que ella
lo siga y solamente las recoja
debía llevarla a ella por el mismo
camino que siga lo socialmente correcto
que cumpla con un mandato impuesto o
debía ayudarla a hacer su propio camino
a ser feliz a que haga lo que le gusta a
que haga lo que le apasiona
pasé de sentirme invencible a vulnerable
a tener dudas a tener cargo de
conciencia
a realmente sentir que necesitaba un
cambio
estaba entre lo que debía hacer y elegir
ser yo misma se acuerdan que les decía
que cuando estaba con la bicicleta yo
sentía extrema felicidad jugando y
trabajando con papá ese cosquilleo que
sentía yo cuando estaba en el taller
durante toda esta etapa que les decía
que era la ejecutiva exitosa no lo había
vuelto a sentir
entonces me preguntaba mis hijos cómo
iban a recordar su infancia y su mamá
trabajando que mamá no tenía tiempo que
vamos al pasado viajando que no podía
compartir con ellos momentos importantes
y les aseguro que para ellos yo no era
un ejecutivo exitosa yo no era
invencible era que mamá no estaba
hasta tres años para ti el tablero de
ribes mi zona de confort deje este mundo
que yo realmente idealizaba
traté de abrir fronteras de romper este
camino que me habían impuesto y darme
cuenta que había otras escapatorias a
este camino entonces lo primero que
decidí es que debía continuar
aprendiendo instruirme
que se imaginan que me puse a estudiar
mecánica de autos y me recibí de técnica
mecánica de autos profesión y decisión
que todavía hoy sorprende y mucho
en este momento que yo en ese momento
que yo estaba estudiando comencé una
etapa de investigación porque quería ver
realmente cómo era la relación de la
mujer y el automóvil
saben que hay un estudio que es mundial
donde a las mujeres se les pregunta de
todos los temas que hoy vos por algún
motivo accedido espacio pediste ayuda al
hombre cuáles son aquellos que quisieras
capacitarte conocer un poco más poder
tomar decisiones por vos misma número
uno son las inversiones o sea hemos
ahorrado dinero que hacemos con ese
dinero número dos son los autos
se sorprenderían si les digo que en
argentina no llegamos al 30 por ciento
de licencias de conducir en manos de
mujeres cuando en países como por
ejemplo estados unidos son más mujeres
que hombres las que manejan
de las mujeres que tienen automóvil el
50% no se anima a llevar el auto al
mecánico le pasa algo al auto entramos
en pánico creemos que nosotros hicimos
algo mal tenemos miedo de ir al mecánico
de cómo se lo vamos a explicar si se van
a reír si nos van a cobrar de más y le
pedimos ayuda a otros para que nos
lleven el auto al mecánico
de las mujeres que tienen vehículos el
70 por ciento jamás ha cambiado un
neumático y yo les pregunto si van en la
ruta están con los chicos pinchan no
tienen señal de celular o se quedaron
sin batería como lo van a resolver
si ya les digo piensan en un automóvil
quien creó cada una de sus partes si
hablo de género me van a decir bueno
esto es una invención de los hombres se
sorprenderían si les digo que la luz de
giro el limpiaparabrisas la calefacción
fueron inventados por mujeres cuando
juntó toda esta información digo acá
tengo mucho por hacer
puse quinta en un camino de empoderar a
la mujer en todo lo relativo a la
industria automotriz decidí en darle
todas las herramientas para que pueda
resolver temas ella sola saben que en el
momento de la compra del vehículo el 85
por ciento de las decisiones de la
compra la realiza la mujer entonces si
nosotros somos la que decidimos sobre la
compra del vehículo porque no se nos
empoderamos más con él
pero como vas a dejar de ser ese
ejecutiva exitosa para ser una mecánica
de autos y empoderar a la mujer en todo
lo relativo a la industria automotriz
les aseguro que soy más feliz que nunca
jo me convertí en una emprendedora me
convertí en la fundadora de lady fierros
clínica de autos no están cansados ya de
escuchar las mujeres manejamos mal no
sabemos nada de autos realmente ya es
momento de tomar el auto por las ruedas
y empoderarnos más con nuestro vehículo
le di fierros comenzó tímidamente en las
redes sociales dando tips y consejos
relativos a los automóviles si ustedes
entran hoy a por ejemplo a instagram a
robar ready fierros de todas las redes
sociales ya tengo más de 300 mil
seguidores
van a ver tips de cómo cambiar un
neumático de qué se trata el tren
delantero la lectura del tablero del
auto etcétera también las recibo en el
taller para que sientan confianza al
momento de explicar cuál es la
problemática del auto y explicarles
correctamente al momento de buscar el
vehículo hasta saben me llaman para que
las acompañe a comprar el auto díganme
si todos si tienen que comprar un auto
usado no tienen dudas de qué
problemática pudo haber tenido el
vehículo pero no solamente impacta desde
ese lugar le di fierros sino también
desde un impacto social no saben la
cantidad de chicas que se están animando
a decir sabes que mamá quería que sea
doctora pero yo quiero hacer mecánica de
autos
esto ayuda a la inserción laboral y es
una posibilidad más para que la mujer se
inserte laboralmente y por otro lado
también nos está animando a que cada vez
haya más mujeres en los transportes
públicos y por qué no en los transportes
de carga
reinventarse dejar ese status quo que no
nos deja avanzar me conforte esa zona de
confort que yo tenía me estaba
impidiendo ayudar a alguien en este caso
el ayudar a la mujer en empoderarse con
su automóvil en acercarse más a la
industria automotriz nosotros somos los
artífices de nuestro propio destino el
éxito no es solamente el de la carrera
profesional que elegimos sino también el
éxito lo alcanzamos cuando estamos
haciendo algo que nos gusta que nos
apasiona que nos genera felicidad
si yo miro para atrás les aseguro que no
me arrepiento de absolutamente nada de
lo que hice y volvería a transitar
exactamente los mismos pasos porque en
este trayecto acumule en esta caja de
herramientas experiencias experiencias
positivas experiencias negativas pero de
todas aprendí y genere una herramienta
que fue la herramienta que me ayudó a
derribar esta zona de confort que no me
dejaba avanzar
por eso les propongo que cuando termine
esta charla se pongan a pensar si
realmente lo que están haciendo es lo
que les apasiona es lo que les gusta es
cómo se ven y no solamente me refiero a
una decisión de una carrera profesional
sino que uno puede comenzar a derribar
zonas de confort desde una actividad
deportiva que siempre me gustó nadar y
nunca nadie me voy a animar y lo voy a
hacer porque porque cuando empezamos a
derribar estas pequeñas zonas de confort
para la próxima van a estar cada vez más
fuertes y plantados para superarse en la
próxima que vengan
si yo les cuento lo más importante que
tengo acá en mi caja de herramientas es
que atesoró que cuando oí a mis hijos le
preguntan qué hace mamá con mucho
orgullo dicen tengo una mamá mecánica de
autos
gracias
belinda
gracias a ustedes
gracias
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]